the lawyers of depraved deplorable and
desperate dishonest Jared Kushner are
now trying to write off the fact that
100 foreign contacts have been added to
the disclosure forms of Jared Kushner
Jared Kushner has yet again updated his
disclosures now totaling over 100 names
that have been added since the original
disclosures were submitted he forgot to
disclose more than 100 meetings this is
part of the process that's required to
obtain a security clearance in the first
place Senator Chris Murphy who's a
Democrat from Connecticut on Wednesday
said in a normal political world Jared
Kushner would no longer have a job
that's true but there's another layer in
a normal world cushion ER would never
even have gotten the job of advisor to
the president in the first place because
it was pure nepotism not experience that
got him that job into the normal world
Donald Trump would not be President yeah
we're not in it Chris Murphy is naively
talking about what would happen in a
normal world we are very very far from
an overt normal world if you lied this
much on disclosures required to get a
job like in the financial field for
example in law enforcement
mostly anywhere and people in charge are
paying attention you would be fired
immediately I mean there's no question
about it whatsoever I know people who
have been denied for internship spat at
financial companies and at the State
Department because there were small
errors like truly just innocent
oversights in disclosure forms and they
were denied internships here we're
talking about someone with a top
security clearance oh it's like if you
say you're bilingual when you're not you
may not get that job this is a whole
nother ballgame here and it's really
difficult because it's not like you can
impeach this guy he would have to be
fired by Trump right and that's not
going to happen when he's the guy's
son-in-law Ivanka would be very angry
with him yeah what might happen though
is he might actually have his security
clearance revoked now Donald Trump could
override that but you know I've heard
various political analysts today saying
if that happens the blowback would be so
severe for Trump overriding that he
probably wouldn't do it I'm not
convinced I actually think Trump
might be naive enough to try to pull
that but yeah number one Kushner should
have his security clearance revoked
period then we can try to figure out to
quote Donald what the hell is going on
and there's two possibilities and
neither suggests that Jared Kushner
should have a security clearance
possibility one is Jared Kushner
deliberately lied about 100 foreign
contacts and in that case he shouldn't
be working at the White House period the
other possibility is that he forgot to
mention 100 foreign contacts or forgot
that he even had 100 foreign contacts
and in that case it's sort of the same
conclusion he shouldn't be working at
the White House period but the problem
as usual is the proved ability of this
if we look at the law on this from the
standard form 86 a that is the
disclosure form it says what you're
basically signing on to is my statements
on this form and on any attachments to
it are true complete and correct to the
best of my knowledge and belief and are
made in good faith I have carefully read
the foregoing instructions to complete
this form I understand that a knowing
and willful false statement on this form
can be punished by fine or imprisonment
or both I understand that intentionally
withholding misrepresenting or
falsifying information may have a
negative effect on my security clearance
it is difficult to prove that he didn't
believe what he submitted at the time
was false right you need to prove intent
and it is very difficult to do and while
he obviously if he's this forgetful he
shouldn't be advising the president that
would not make it a crime I think
kushner resigning is the only way to get
him out of that White House and maybe at
this point with the Russia story adding
up his lawyers are going to start urging
him to do that it's just a real shame
though because I don't want him to get
led away in handcuffs before he figures
out peace in the Middle East I know
that's we're going to talk about that
later and he is on the verge of solving
the israeli-palestinian conflict if you
believe Donald Trump and it might be
shocking to you to hear his hat and it's
it's shocking to me too
this isn't good for Kushner this isn't
good for Trump do you
greep at that Kushner's is one of the
most exposed Trump staffers to criminal
prosecution absolutely yeah absolutely
now who is second I think it's him in
Flint him in Flint I think are the most
at risk Oh Paul mana for mana for heart
age maybe we don't really know with
Paige I don't know I don't even mr.
necessarily put them on that list okay
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
our EDD IT today's episode made possible
by taga dabs a hosting specialist taga
dev offers a range of flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options they also do custom
server solutions and colocation services
taga dab has a really user-friendly
interface and excellent customer support
team their expert hosting specialists
also are their friendly support team and
they give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of nine point
seven out of ten you know that taga dab
takes their customer service very very
seriously with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud tag
Adad is offering you as a david packard
show viewer or listener a twenty british
pound free credits about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers signing up
to give you a chance to try their
services to take advantage of it go to
signup tag adapt calm /td PS for more
information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up tag adapt calm slashed edps
use the discount code TDPS 20